happy Wednesday everyone it's been a
great week so far cat's still on her
honeymoon yeah I think we have tape
at least we know they're still alive
that's not back look who is
yes another blonde psychopath
oh she's not that bad okay she is you
know I bet she was the Secretary of
State
you know I was the Secretary of State I
spent you know many days on airplanes
flying from place to place encouraging
people uh to have a real democracy in
one of the Hallmarks of a real democracy
is the peaceful transfer of power
yeah well you know what else is a
Hallmark of democracy a free and fair
election and the right to [ __ ] about it
if you didn't think it was just that you
know kind of like you did you old gas
bag and sensible shoes
and Hillary you remember Libya's
peaceful transfer of power right it
ended up with two Civil Wars murdered
Americans and you saying what difference
does it make
anyway apparently she was a guest on The
View which is like sprinkling sawdust on
vomit
I don't even know what that means really
if that's a good thing it could be but I
wonder if she would not be honest if she
didn't say there was a seditious
conspiracy against the government of the
United States
I would not be honest if I didn't say I
think there was a seditious conspiracy
against the government of the United
States and that's a crime led by Donald
Trump led by Donald Trump encouraged by
Donald Trump yeah you know she had a
point when she said I would not be
honest
but it's really just Collective Amnesia
and everyone's playing along except for
our very own dumb son of a [ __ ] Peter
Ducey
take it away Peter you tweeted
stole an election I was waiting Peter
when you were going to ask me that
question she was waiting for it yet was
still shockingly unprepared for it
uh poor kgp she checked every box for
the job except competence
well at least Peter asked the question
that no one else in the media dared to
ask since it would destroy their
anti-trump narratives remember
questioning elections is an Insurrection
unless you're a Democrat
but it's about motivating the base to
vote through fear that's why the Biden
speech last week was so dark and angry
in case you forgot here's a clip
[Applause]
sorry that was Hunter Biden getting the
results of his latest STD test
anyway so I repeat after me the
Republicans are extreme Trump is a
fascist parents are terrorists and I'm
too handsome for TV
all lies except for that one
so how do you fight fake fear well you
do so with real fear fact is the real
problems facing Americans are scarier
than Hillary in a two-piece eating a
three-piece
got sky high crime persistent inflation
a school system that prefers
indoctrination over education with drag
shows on demand at your local Middle
School it's all brought to you by
left-wing policies we don't have to Gin
up fear people getting pushed in front
of subways is stronger than any
hyperbole which is why the media and the
Dems need to push fake misery fake fear
to drown out the real
two of the Hallmarks of a fascist
political party are one they don't
accept the results of elections that
don't go their way into they Embrace
political violence and I think that's
why President Biden was right to sound
the alarm this week about these
continuing attacks on our constitutional
order from the outside by Donald Trump
and his movement if you look up fascism
in the dictionary
so I'm really not sure what the
Republicans are all upset about other
than the fact that it was named I love
how she pretends to use a dictionary
now don't let all this fascist talk get
to you like my Proctologist told me in
my last visit keep your powder dry
it's just a sign of desperation it's a
sign of desperation by desperate people
you know like when Brian Kilmeade stands
under the mistletoe
their ideas fail their policies reward
the bad and punish the good they have
nothing to sell except fear that the
Alternatives even worse than they are
that should be the line that Joe's
remembered for when historians look back
we have nothing to sell but fear itself
he's plagiarized everybody else why not
FDR but it's got to suck to be a
Democrat voter your address is a vacant
lot and the only way to get you to care
about something is to make you feel
awful it's like how panhandlers use
underfed dogs oh your poor puppy here's
some money for heroin
so what about voters who are on the
fence if they look at two competing
fears which one is more motivating well
first of all how can a voter be on the
fence when these two parties are so far
apart that's like someone tried to
straddle the Grand Canyon that's like
someone's saying I can't decide what
tickets to buy one's to Maui or to
Maroon 5.
or a guy wanting to surprise his wife on
their 20th anniversary is it a diamond
ring or two tickets to WrestleMania
but one fear is obviously
yeah I should have read the room
but one fear is obviously phony it's the
left accusing everyone else of being
fascists who are pushing for civil war
it's a claim that's easily destroyed
every time you walk outside and see
people getting along together it's
ridiculous how little our politics
matter in everyday life because we have
lives which is why the right should be
talking about real world fears created
by Democrat policies no cash bail reduce
sentencing turning grand larceny into a
lesser outrage than littering those are
real concerns but who's the best at
pushing it
well the Dems are lucky they can push
their fears and the media is on board
but you talk about real stuff like crime
immigration inflation the media calls
you fascist for daring to suggest
practical solutions to these serious
problems but that's fine focus on
reality and let them live in their
fantasy land and maybe it's not a bad
thing that they think you're a fascist
it'll keep them from borrowing your
lawnmower
[Applause]
yes welcome tonight's guest she has two
more awards for women and journalism
than I do anchor of the story Martha
McCallum
he's Mr Clean on the outside and Perry
Mason on the inside former acting
attorney general Matt Whitaker
she's the only lawyer that commutes by
cartwheel outnumbered co-host Emily
capagno
it's a good thing for him that he
doesn't suffer from altitude sickness
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Television Champion Tyron
thank you
Martha how do you take Biden's kind of
like
um I don't know kind of uh agenda of
fear I think it happens to be somewhat
effective because we're talking about it
but do you think it's going to work well
you know as this as I say he's leaning
into it he feels like it works I I was
struck by that video again of him with
the red background yeah you couldn't see
the Marines on either side of him as he
was doing that it's a very strange he's
very pale in that video it's a very very
odd image and I think you make a great
point about what they are not talking
about which is the horrific scenes of
crime you know you could throw a stick
out and you could find a million videos
of horrific things that are happening to
people people being you know cold cocked
in the subway and hitting their head and
ending up in the hospital all kinds of
you know the other thing that really
strikes me is the images of people
getting off the buses here in New York
City and having their hands shaken and I
keep thinking about you know you showed
kyrgios uh last night smashing his
racket at the U.S open you know and
porno back Djokovic can't can't get into
the country yeah meanwhile everybody
who's in fans getting shaken and brought
into the city I mean who knows whether
or not they've had a vaccine that's a
great point I didn't think of that
mainly because I never watched tennis oh
yeah you're missing out I had no idea
that they actually televise it you know
because I mean I understand sorry I'm I
know I I mean I understand pickleball
completely but Tennessee yes
pickleball completely let's be honest
tennis is just basically a rip-off of
pickleball you could never have tennis
without first pickleball
absolutely yes exactly right right on no
tennis you know tennis is a poor man's
pickleball I think I coined that phrase
Matt you know you look like a fascist
but
right he's like a fascist teddy bear he
likes it's not better he'll kill you
with it he offered me a hug before we
were walking in here it was very nice
what is uh how do you feel about you
there's a group of people who probably
think that you're a fascist because you
know you're a Republican and you know
because I stood for the rule of law yes
because I do the right thing for the
right reason all the you know those
because I don't I want less crime
because I worried about wearing this
watch in New York City today for fear of
motorcycles running up and ripping it
off my arm I would love to see somebody
try to mug you though that would be
funny
serious I mean like coming to New York
City is it's thrilling but for the wrong
reasons yeah because you get the tingle
uh that maybe you know hasn't happened
since Barack Obama was elected yeah but
you know it's a fear tingle and not I
get that a lot after I well anyway
I think we've all had the fear tingle
did you see Hillary Clinton uh in that
same interview she she's a friendly
media she never comes to the difficult
question like Martha would do yeah and
so she was able to say oh Jim Comey said
I didn't have any classified information
after the fact it's like no he didn't
yeah I mean she just made this story up
but now she said it nobody's challenging
yeah so it's out there I tried to look
for that and I just assumed what she
said it so it must have happened no but
it didn't happen
so that's crazy see
Emily wow you're tan hi yeah where were
you
um Greece and then the Jersey Shore oh
wow both of them Paradise fantastic uh
what do you want to talk about you want
to talk about about Hillary or fear well
both because I think you you just hit
the nail on the head when you said oh I
assumed it was true when I heard her say
that and the biggest thing that strikes
me in addition to the blatant hypocrisy
from the left is the gaslighting the
sheer gaslighting that keeps coming out
of mouthpieces of this Administration so
you know Hillary it's okay for her to
have classified emails on her server but
God forbid if if former president Trump
has something of the like in his
situation that they're currently
undergoing whatever
um you know God forbid if green
Jean-Pierre says oh I I didn't mean it
oh I knew you would say that if she
knows that Peter juicy is going to bring
up her claims of a stolen election in
multiple instances by the way then why
wasn't she prepared but why doesn't she
acknowledge then the severity of it but
it's not okay for other people to say it
that our members of the GOP it's okay
for Kathy Griffin to call for Civil War
if Republicans are voted into office for
Maxine Waters to call for violence but
if some member of the GOP or the right
or some type of designated fascist says
that then all of a sudden that should be
taken seriously so to your point they're
brushing off these statistics these
horrible things that are happening in
democrat-led cities and bail reform that
is leading to real people being hurt and
murdered in their families suffering
because it doesn't suit their agenda but
they're going to keep gaslighting until
we vote everyone out in November which
is coming yeah Tyrus it's basically
oh yeah I'm always touched when they
applaud my questions
[Laughter]
you didn't even ask it yet I mean that's
good I know I know but you know the
anticipation they often have to control
their nerves by clapping yes
anyway rare rare skill yes yo Tyrus what
we're seeing is we're seeing this
imagined war and then like real
struggles what advice would you give the
Republicans it seems like they're not
picking up on this you know my advice
would be just kind of sit there yeah
because they're obviously shifts right
in this screenplay and it's it's not
going to get picked up yes they they
continue to live in in fake fear worlds
and and and it's almost entertaining the
fact that he would go to that much
trouble there was a team to put that
together yeah you know apparently they
had watched a Star Wars marathon the
night before you know and you know the
only thing he didn't say only the thing
he didn't say was like the windmills
will be fully operational you know like
there's only it's just they just try
they live in that exterior we always
talk about and they stay there because
you can pick and pull and if you call
them on it they just change it why
wasn't she prepared in the first world
you don't have to be prepared anytime
you ask a question you can just answer
with another question so that's what
drives us crazy well we need to stay
focused on is voting them out because
let's be fair
if they wanted a Civil War I think the
Republicans are the wrong ones to call
it on for one we're not going to burn
down our own City first you know and
yeah by the time you guys try to figure
out how to work the little guns you were
trying to get rid of yes right
Fair Point
yeah I I strongly suggest you rethink
that yes that's not a good formation
she's a comedian maybe it was just a
really good joke yes I was joking yes
exactly at least she's back in the news
good for her I say come on the show
Kathy we'll have a great time right so
bring the severed heads
yes hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else